so with your
kind of early
love or appreciation of the beauty of
mathematics do you see a parallel
between that world and the world of
programming
you know programming is all about
logical structure
understanding the the patterns
that um come out of
computation understanding
sort of i mean it's often
like you know the path through the graph
of possibilities
to find a short a short route
meaning like uh find a short program
that gets the job done
yeah kind of thing but so then on the
topic of irrational numbers
do you see dc programming
you just painted it so cleanly uh it's a
little this trajectory
to find like a nice little program but
do you see it as fundamentally messy
maybe unlike mathematics i don't think
of it as i mean
i mean you know you watch somebody who's
good at math do
math and you know often
it's it's fairly messy sometimes it's
kind of
magical um
when i was a grad student
um one of the students his name was jim
sax
was he had this this this
this this reputation of being sort of a
walking talking human uh theorem proving
machine
and if you were having a hard problem
with something you could just like
accost him in the hall and say jim
and and he would do this this this funny
thing where he would
stand up straight his eyes would kind of
defocus he'd
go uh you know just just like you you
know like like
something in today's movies you just
yeah
and then you straighten up and say n log
in and walk away
and and you go well okay so n log n is
the answer how did he
get there
by which time he's you know down the
hallway somewhere yeah
it's just the the oracle the black boxes
gives you the answer
yeah and then you have to figure out the
path from the question to the answer
you